the Joe Rogan experience or there's a
gun you know she's the matriarch of the
of the Clinton family and there she is
the hero to many people of the
Democratic Party and you two are
scrapping it does that start when you
did that start you did you supported
Bernie in 2016 is that where it started
yeah okay and that was something yeah
back in 2016 I was the vice chair of the
Democratic National Committee therefore
as an officer the DNC had to remain
neutral in the presidential election
which was my plan to do so I really made
the decision to resign from that seat so
that I could endorse Bernie Sanders
largely be car actually largely because
of his difference with Hillary Clinton
in foreign policy you know Hillary
Clinton had you know very much of an
interventionist in my opinion kind of
the the Warhawk regime change war policy
that she had shown throughout her time
both in the administration as well as as
a u.s. senator and Bernie Sanders you
know lean the other way he's more of a
non interventionist and I saw that in
the those debates at that time the
conversations that were and the media
was not bringing up this difference
between the two of them so the voters
could make an informed choice of who
they want their commander-in-chief to be
which to me just as you know as a
soldier as a veteran as in America I'm
like how can you not be putting this
issue at the forefront so I resigned
from that position endorse Bernie
Sanders started going out and just
talking about and raising these issues
on the campaign trail but I remember one
of the first interviews that I did on
MSNBC the host of the show saying aren't
you afraid of what the Clintons will do
to you said this on live television you
know my answer was no obviously but it
was amazing it was it was interesting to
see the reaction like the days after
when I first went back to DC after I
made that announcement of endorsement
and friends of mine you know politicians
in Washington they were like man tulsi
like go with God
sister
it's a different animal we'll see like
if you get into some sort of verbal
altercation with Joe Biden there's no
concern for your life I'm not saying
it's real or not
yeah but the rumor is always there's a
thing called oh yeah
joke I don't think it is really some of
it most of it let's say it's all made up
the fact that that's out there that the
thought is out there that they will
whack you well there's there's I mean
the people who are saying hey look you
know there are lists that are kept in
your political career will be over that
was really the message that I got from
from people who've been around the block
a few times
that takes a take now let's change
everything yeah they do they take down
they take downs change everything I'm
soda elbows in the clinch soda had head
butts head butts change everything - you
know I had David LaDuke in here from
that way yeah watch his fights watch
some of those left boy fights you
realize like that's legit man Rory once
he was like he was between contracts and
he's like look me a fighter let way I'm
like why do you want to fight that was
like because now's the time or else I'll
never get to fight with headbutts before
I resign he wanted me to take him down
to the jungles of let me fight for $10
against some guy we don't know no
medical tests you know he's a foreigner
they wanna you know like it's just he's
nuts I was like no that's a very bad
idea psych come on I'll never get to
fight with headbutts or else I'm like
okay I hope you never fight with him I
hope the day never comes
[Applause]